this one belongs to the utah jazz as
they ride their star
donovan mitchell 51 tonight for mitchell
utah
up 3-1 in this best of seven
such a great job of effort by denver
but i tell you what it was donovan
mitchell you just seen
him will his team ever since game one
and again i'm impressed by the scoring
in the shooting but i'm more impressed
by the decision-making
because he had 50 points got other guys
involved played tough
and played the pick and roll as best as
it could be played tonight
to jared greenberg i got donovan
mitchell with me who ba you know
has done some television work with us so
i'm going to ask you to be an analyst
here
if i were to tell you that michael
jordan allen iverson
and now donovan mitchell are the only
three men in nba history to have
multiple 50-point games
in a same playoff series what would you
say about that
they won i haven't done anything yet uh
to be honest with you
all i did was all we did was win game
four um
50 is 50 but you know we're looking to
close the series out man i
i mean i i'm honored to be in that
category don't get me wrong and i'm very
humbled and blessed but
you know we still got one more game left
jared and that's really what's on my
mind we fought hard and
we knew they were gonna come out and
that was a big that was a big game for
all of us and that's really where my
head is at and
i'm tired i bet you are after you hit
your last three-pointer of the night
right around the same spot that luca
doncic hit his three earlier in the
night
we our cameras caught you saying i want
this and then something else
how badly do you want this man this is
without bullion you know
i'm not going to say much right now we
have one more game um but without
boiling
we it really shows what what type of
team we have man and
you know i think for me you know i
understand i didn't really have a great
playoffs last year
and for me just putting the work in and
that's just all summer work
uh quarantine work whatever you want to
call it at the end of the day man
i had 50. mike conley had 26. rudy had
17 and 11.
uh royce played a hell of a defense the
mall had 50 man like we gotta give him
credit but
we fought and works and that's really
where i'm at you know and
we got one more game and i want to win i
know we want to win i speak for my
teammates when i say we want this
you know what i'm saying way to censor
yourself appreciate that everybody back
in atlanta appreciates that as well
uh looking ahead last one for you what
what do you need to do to make sure you
close out this series in five
we can't let up you know they we knew
they're going to come out with
aggression and fight
but we can't be complacent you know
we're going to they're going to be even
more hungry for next game to get this to
get the next one but we got to stay
locked in and do what we do
we showed a hell of an effort but
there's we gave up 127 points there's
stuff we can fix
and for us to win that game with stuff
that we didn't really do too well on
that's impressive but we're gonna go
back in watch the film and be ready for
game five
the leading scorer in the bubble donovan
mitchell put up another 50 spot thank
you donovan
tell you what ba i mean he had 29 in the
second half 18 in the fourth quarter he
dished out a bunch of assists but
i love the most he has a bunch of
humility he knows he has one more game
left
coffee coffee's for closers and he
closed that one